oh so so so so so I the basic building
block of this course i PT right hmm what
is the basic building block of this
course what do you reckon
what would you call it processes yeah
anyone else were like a building block
is that smallest thing that you know it
that makes up everything else I can
answer my suppose okay so you could say
like oh wow that's smooth and not a bad
answer if I shouldn't press into
knowledge
okay I'm going to suggest hmmm put this
information precision technology right
there a bit like your forgive me I've
been watching a lot of science videos
recently there have been like electrons
protons neutrons okay you can consider
them on their own and actually you can
take one of those people used to think
they were indivisible but you can divide
them up into quarks and sub quarks and
that kind of thing okay however in the
real world right not in labs you don't
just get electrons flying around doing
their thing or purpose you know here's a
lonely proton it's like I've got their
friends okay in the real world we have
atoms right which are combinations of
those and then they do different things
yeah so I think if you took your eyes
and your peers and your teasing you put
them all together what do you get you
get an information system right so um I
think this the system is kind of like
the atom if you like and we've been
looking at through the course so far now
they are in communication systems okay
the atom of a communication system is a
network if you don't have a network you
don't have a communication system okay
you can't have transmitting or receiving
unless there's some kind of arrangement
of different it's a system which can
communicate within itself okay so if you
like it to specialize cly in their
system yeah so um we're going to talk
about networks a lot over the next few
lessons so need to introduce that term
and a few more terms so let's have a go
today add on this idea of a node
what's a nerd um what do we get
where would you see the word node in
like other fields
whether other areas of study frosting it
means in your your your body has a
lymphatic system and that's got that's
got nose I think yeah what else say yeah
okay yes so when light-emitting diodes
right they've got nodes in the visual
they're kind of what what are they lymph
nodes these things they're sort of the
small pieces that come together to make
the network right so in in our terms
right what are the nose what are the
individual pieces that come together to
make a network it's basically any device
they can connect to a network so that
means you're all typing at nodes right
now right if you're typing on the
computer okay your keyboard is not known
because a keyboard by itself can't plug
into a network right but the whole
computer can okay so that computer is
the device that can plug into the
network what other kinds of things can
plug into networks and stand on their
own like a keyboard can't but it comes
you two can what count what else good so
sorry let's um let's have a little solve
this tear right
so we said computers which are the main
kind right we set printers anything else
that you can plug into a network which
isn't one of these okay good
you're all accessing the internet right
now but you're not accessing it to a
computer or a printer ultimately you're
accessing through something that can
plug into another network right I'm not
like that the telephone network so
that's a modem right anything else
as tricky isn't it if we said say a hard
drive right because I said keyboards it
wouldn't really make sense now a hard
drive sort of can sort of if you provide
it with the right kind of extra pieces
right so hard drive connected to a
network we would usually call it a file
server right it's sort of like a
glorified hard drive right it's a big
hard drive and the computer that it's
attached to it probably doesn't have a
screen probably doesn't have a keyboard
or a mouse
because people don't need to actually
directly interact with it it's other
computers that need to get stuff off it
okay just on that idea of servers right
they're called servers because the point
of this device is to serve all the other
ones no one's actually like I said no
one's actually sitting up file server or
the print server or the proxy server no
one's using those computers directly
they're busy serving other computers
does that make sense okay
so all of these are what we call nodes
now that leads me on to the next
question which is when you connect nodes
together you get something called a
topology where's the lab topology
usually come from this Illinois where is
it borrowed from it's borrowed from
geography or what is a topology in
geography does anyone know
um we usually associate it with
something like this let me see let me
see how badly I can draw this with you
so something like this
and then like there's something bigger
your honor I don't know you get the idea
okay so I'm sort of looking at some
hills and like a sand you know or some
kind of mollusk that's gone crazy anyway
alright so what's this this is uh we
call these contour lines right so they
describe I usually describe altitude
that they're right we would say this is
a topology this is the topology of some
kind of area it tells you physically
sort of how it's ranged what the
important features are that kind of
thing okay now it networks a network
topology is just the same thing sort of
if you like it's kind of like the
landscape this is a synonym for you the
landscape of a network okay it's how the
nodes fit together
okay
nodes if you have more than two you can
fit them together all kinds of different
ways a bit like Lego right you can put
one piece on top of another or you can
attach them to the sides or that kind of
thing lots of different alternatives
okay and we're going to look at some of
those alternatives before we leave off
that I want to remind you of these two
different categories logical versus
physical now when do we study these two
what process were we looking at we
thought about is general remember we
will again processing while we talk
about logical and physical arrangements
and their difference when we're looking
at processing
there was this idea right that you can
describe something based on its function
okay yes okay
so I could say look I have this thing I
actually have two of them I have two
things called eyes and what's then
what's the purpose what's the function
of my eye
it's to a set incoming well we call it
it's it's electromagnetic radiation in a
certain spectrum right which we call the
visible spectrum and it's meant to come
in and my eyes have the job of
interpreting that and turning them into
signals which my brain can understand
okay that's the job of my eyes and to
recognize different things around me
okay so that's the function of my eye
right and then you can talk about
physically how to do that and you know
you could draw that you seen it right
just how does it look it's got a thing
over here and then it's like a no
there's some blood vessels going out
there I didn't do very well apologies
you can tell okay
so here's here's my eye from sidon this
is the physical arrangement yes okay but
then I could say logically in terms of
function the housefly that was bothering
me yesterday afternoon has something
which has exactly the same function
right it's about accepting incoming
light and interpreting and trying to
feed it to its brain but it's physical
form is very different
okay yeah it's a pretty good one so I'm
not very good at illustrating right but
you can tell that this side is pretty
different to this side right so
physically about about as different as
as you could get at least I hope that's
not what you think when you look at me
okay but logically in terms of function
they're the same notice it okay now
therefore what does this have to do it
networks okay I can describe a network
this way or this way okay all the
topologies that we're talking about
there on this side okay how something
fits together physically they may look
very very different okay just keep that